Мурал на будинку, у якому живе Ірина Машовець, -
нагадування про її загиблого чоловіка.
Сергій Машовець був активістом, волонтером, головою громадської організації "Парк Осокорки".
На муралі - епізоди з його життя: Революція Гідності, парк, який Сергій мріяв
створити в Дарницькому районі столиці, повномасштабне вторгнення Росії.
На той момент я була на 4-му місяці вагітності.
Сергій залишив нас у батьків і сам поїхав долучитись до своїх хлопців.
Вже 24 лютого мій чоловік приєднався до ТРО "Азов Київ".
Вони були відповідальні за безпеку міста Києва зі сторони Ірпеня, Бучі, Горенки.
В інтерв'ю журналістам New York Times 13 березня Сергій розповідає,
що напередодні офіційно одружився з Іриною перед тим, як вона виїхала з країни.
Сказала, що нікуди не поїде, поки не одружимося.
Наступного дня Сергій загинув.
Мій чоловік загинув 14 березня 22-го року, в перший день добровольця.
Так якось доля вирішила. Він загинув поблизу села Горенка.
Це був артобстріл, але ще досі ми точно не знаємо обставини,
тому що в їхню машину влучили.
Нині Ірина сама виховує двох доньок. Молодша народилася за чотири місяці
після загибелі батька. Родина Сергія Машовця досі не отримала жодної допомоги від держави.
Є проблема в тому, що не були поставлені відмітки в військоматі,
тобто мій чоловік не був практично правильно мобілізований.
Ми зіштовхнулися в цей же момент з тим, що наша законодавча база
абсолютно не відповідає новим реаліям, що в перелік військових
чи спецпризначенців взагалі не вносяться добровольці.
Вони однаково захищали країну, але мають тепер різну вагу серед законів.
У перші дні повномасштабного вторгнення тисячі українців добровільно взяли до рук зброю.
Ніхто не думав про офіційне оформлення.
Але згодом з'ясувалося, що добровольці не можуть претендувати ані на статус
учасника бойових дій, ані на виплати.
Закон про визнання добровольців з'явився майже через рік після початку вторгнення.
А постанова, яка регулює його виконання, - ще через пів року.
Лише в серпні 2023 року родина Сергія Машовця змогла отримати статус
родини загиблого Захисника. Про виплати поки взагалі не йдеться.
Так зване "сіре" посвідчення - доказ того, що Сергій Машовець загинув у бойових діях
- поки все, що отримала від держави його дружина Ірина.
Для того, щоб отримати [посвідчення], нам дуже багато потрібно було документів,
первинної медичної документації, яка б підтверджувала безпосередню участь,
що травма, каліцтво, контузія, смерть настала саме в результаті воєнних дій.
Але це був лише початок. З'ясувалося, що за нинішнім законодавством,
добровольці та їхні родини не можуть отримати такі ж соціальні гарантії, що й військовослужбовці.
Одноразова виплата у разі загибелі добровольця становить 750 прожиткових мінімумів.
У 2023 році це трошки більше 2 мільйонів гривень.
Зауважу, що родичі загиблого військовослужбовця у разі загибелі військового
отримують 15 мільйонів під час воєнного стану.
Крім того, літні батьки й діти загиблих добровольців нині не мають права
на так звані "військові" пенсії - 7800 гривень на місяць.
Можуть отримати лише виплату за втрату годувальника - близько двох тисяч.
У нас була зустріч із заступником керівника пенсійного фонду.
Виходячи з нашої зустрічі, ми зрозуміли, що пенсії можуть бути такі ж,
як у родин військовослужбовців. Для цього, скоріш за все, потрібно трохи змінити законодавство,
внести певні зміни. Наскільки я розумію, пенсійний фонд
буде допомагати в цьому і просуватиме ці зміни.
На думку юристів, цілком можливо також урівняти одноразові виплати родинам
загиблих військовослужбовців і добровольців - по 15 мільйонів гривень.
Це дуже просто зробити, потрібно просто внести категорію добровольців,
цю категорію до постанови 168, і таким чином тоді родини загиблих
зможуть отримати таку виплату.
Чи готовий прем'єр-міністр прийняти це рішення, це політичне рішення.
Можна зрозуміти, що вони не знають, яка це кількість людей, яка кількість родин.
Тобто на сьогоднішній день родини тільки почали подаватися на статус оформлення,
і яка це кількість родин, для яких потрібно встановити цю виплату, поки що невідомо.
Але ми в той же час хочемо почути, що вони готові взагалі це рішення розглядати.
Питаннями визнання так званих "неоформлених" добровольців
і правами їхніх родин опікується міністерство ветеранів.
Неофіційно родинам загиблих добровольців там говорили: побоюються,
що претендентів на виплати може виявитися так багато, що бюджет міністерства
не потягне таке навантаження.
Хоча офіційні цифри говорять про інше. На запит DW у міністерстві ветеранів повідомили:
станом на початок жовтня 39 загиблих добровольців визнані такими,
що брали участь у бойових діях. Ще 10 заяв відправили на уточнення,
а в 11 випадках - відмовили. На розгляді - 21 заява.
Тобто людей, які претендують на виплати, наразі не так і багато.
Скільки ще таких родин, зокрема в прикордонних регіонах, які першими прийняли
на себе удар, справді невідомо, кажуть юристи. Чимало хто з родичів взагалі
можуть не знати, що мають право на державну підтримку.
Ірина Машовець налаштована відстоювати свої права.
Каже: заради дітей та інших родин загиблих добровольців.
Тут навіть питання стоїть не в тому, щоб просто отримати цю одноразову грошову допомогу
чи отримати пенсійне забезпечення. А взагалі - в справедливості і ставленні.
Тому що не можна зменшити чиїсь досягнення, щоб його зробити просто
учасником бойових дій і забути про нього.
Ірина продовжує справу чоловіка в громадській організації "Парк Осокорки".
Працює у волонтерському хабі й допомагає військовим.
Їй складно збагнути, чому чиновники не прагнуть допомогти їй та іншим родинам
загиблих добровільних захисників і захисниць.
Адже невідомо, якою була б нині Україна, якби добровольці не стали
на її захист у перші дні повномасштабного вторгнення.